most of the attention at the moment is
focused on events overseas and this is
understandable to some extent as the
current conflict in the Middle East is
obviously very important and has
far-reaching implications the problem is
that first of all our own leaders do not
appear to be focusing on the right
things as it relates to that conflict
namely they should be focusing on doing
everything they possibly can to avoid
World War II like that should be the top
priority but they seem entirely
uninterested in avoiding a global
conflict if anything they're motivated
in the opposite ction uh many of them
seem to want a World War and if they
want it then they'll get it second as
our gaze is directed at events thousands
of miles away our own country finds
itself in an increasingly dire situation
we may soon have a uh sort of Middle
East style chaos in this country thanks
to our own undefended unprotected
borders in fact I probably shouldn't use
the word may there's no May about it it
will happen we are inviting it and I'll
show you what I mean but first let's go
back to one of the biggest lessons from
9/11 which is that hindsight bias can
get people killed so here's how a lot of
people thought prior to 911 they figured
well no terrorist has ever hijacked or
or has hijacked a US commercial aircraft
anywhere in the world for well over a
decade you know at that point it been a
decade and uh they certainly have never
flown them into buildings and therefore
it's crazy to worry about any terror
group hijacking planes and flying them
in buildings they haven't done it before
pretty much everyone in avation thought
like that in fact um just uh months
before 9/11 the leader of a major pilot
safety Association publicly opposed the
idea of reinforc cockpit doors and he
said quote even if you make a vault out
of the door if they have't new surround
my flight attendants neck I'm not I I am
going to open the door so there's no
point in having the reinforced doors was
his point the 911 Commission put that
quote in their report because the
Pilot's attitude reflected FAA guidance
at the time which stated that airplane
Crews should basically just do whatever
hijackers want because there's no way
that they're going to grab the controls
and turn the plane into a missile for
example well the moment the terrorists
hijacked four commercial airliners and
flew three of them into buildings and
one of them into the ground everybody on
the planet immediately understood how
wrong the old way of thinking was you
don't discount the risk of a particular
type of terrorist attack by saying it
hasn't happened yet instead you look for
vulnerabilities in the existing syst
system uh that we that we have because
obviously you know the bad guys are
doing the same thing and that was
supposedly all learned and settled after
911 but apparently um this lesson has
not been learned or at least it's been
forgotten or just ignored at least in
Washington last month Republicans on the
house Judiciary Committee held a hearing
to investigate how an operative with
ties to Isis had managed to smuggle more
than a dozen migrants migrants from
usbekistan into the United States
through the southern border order now
the FBI still has no idea exactly how
many usbekistan is this Isis Smuggler
allowed into this country nor do they
have any way to track them all down
they're lost in the wind which isn't
surprising given that this past fiscal
year there were more illegal Crossings
at the border than at any other time in
the history of this
country um well how are Democrats
preferred quote unquote immigration
experts responding to this
development for uh lesson on that here's
a clip from last month's house Judiciary
Committee hearing in which a vice
president at the libertarian KO
Institute explains that Republicans are
fear-mongering about the Border why well
because uh illegal migrants haven't
conducted any terrorist attacks yet
watch the title of this hearing is
terrorist entry through the Southwest
border when I first heard that was the
title my reaction was what terrorist
entry through the Southwest border zero
people have been murdered and attacks
committed by terrorists who entered as
illegal immigrants zero people have been
Mur injured in attacks committed by
terrorists who entered illegally zero
attacks have been carried out by
immigrants who entered
illegally so that's the logic it's kind
of a n a pre- 911 logic and Democrats
are nodding along terrorists haven't
used the wide openen Southern border to
conduct a large- scale terrorist attack
so far and therefore you're paranoid for
thinking that it's a possibility that's
the idea and pretty much every Democrat
in Congress endorses this view which is
you know it's kind of like saying that
you should just leave the door of your
house wide open at night while you go to
sleep because well you've never been the
victim of a home invasion robbery before
it hasn't happened yet and therefore it
will never happen and therefore there's
no reason to do anything to prevent it
from happening this is how they're
they're responding to the news that Isis
is bringing in migrants from usbekistan
that are completely unvetted we don't
know anything about them that's despite
the fact that usbekistan has a long
history of exporting terrorists to this
country on Halloween night in 2017 for
example a 29-year-old usbeck migrant who
was here on a Visa drove a truck into
pedestrians and uh and cyclist in
Manhattan killing eight of them and
wounding many more that attack followed
the sentencing of another usbeck migrant
also here on a Visa who was found guilty
of terrorism charges for planning to
bomb Coney Island now Democrats and
Libertarians apparently want you to
ignore all of that because those iscani
terrorists didn't arrive through the
southern border they came on a plane
therefore they're saying you have no
reason to worry about border security
because they're just they would come on
a plane um it's a totally nonsensical
approach obviously but that's that's
what they're going with Republicans for
the most part you know they're not
focused on it one way or another they
want you to focus on Ukraine in the
Middle East Mitch McConnell who's
somehow is still in office says Ukraine
is our top priority right now now as a
result of this um bipartisan consensus
in Washington this decision to focus on
every other border except our own
there's now a very real risk that
Americans will die in fact Americans are
already dying if not from terrorism then
from gang violence and other kind of
violence that comes across the border as
CNN reported the episode involving the
Isis Smuggler was so alarming that an
urgent classified intelligence report
was circulated to President Joe Biden's
top cabinet officials in their morning
briefing book for some counterterrorism
officials it shows that the US is deeply
vulnerable to the possibility that
terrorists could sneak across the
southern border by hiding amid the surge
of migrants entering the country in
search of
Asylum now to be clear the Biden
Administration uh they aren't simply
ignoring the problem that'd be bad
enough they are actually facilitating it
last week Pure Talk announced that they
would alleviate $10 million in veteran
debt by Veterans Day how are they going
to do all by giving a portion of every
new order to this cause thanks to your
support Pure Talk is 27% to their goal
with three weeks to go our veterans gave
everything to protect our nation and
Pure Talk understands the sacrifices
they've made when you switch to Pure
Talk uh and they're Lightning Fast 5G
Network they'll donate a portion of
every new order to this noble cause you
can make a real difference just by
choosing Superior cell phone service a
winwin for everybody P Talk's plan start
at just 20 bucks a month offering
unlimited talk text more data and a p a
mobile hotspot as well just go to Pur
talk.com Walsh and make the switch let's
rally together show our unwavering
support for our veterans visit Pur
talk.com and switch to pure talk today
it's the right move and it's the
American way after 911 the US government
started using a category called special
interest aliens which is kind of a funny
euphemism but the idea is to flag
migrants coming from countries that
promote terrorism such as usbekistan
these are the special interest um aliens
the idea was was was to be transparent
with Americans about who exactly is
coming into this country and from where
but the Biden Administration has has
decided to hide all of that data because
they don't want us to know at the same
hearing we just showed you Todd benman
of the center for immigration studies
also testified he told lawmakers that
quote uh the Biden Administration has
taken steps to obscure the number of
special interest aliens from the US
public ending routine reporting of these
apprehensions by nationality and indeed
On the Border Patrol website they don't
list the number of special interest
migrants coming from the vast majority
of Muslim countries they don't want you
to know how many people Isis could be
bringing to this country from places
like pistan and other
places but many of those numbers uh have
leaked out anyway in spite of the B
administration's best efforts and Tom
benman told the house Judiciary
Committee uh what those numbers show it
turns out that our Southern border is so
overwhelmed with migrants that we're not
able to effectively screen special
interest aliens at all
watch expect those screening programs to
be degraded indefinitely because vast
numbers of special interest aliens are
currently pouring through the D in gap
between Columbia and Panama usually
10,000 migrants or less pass through the
Gap in 2023 however 300,000 Plus have
gone through the Gap and whereas only
3,000 or 4,000 special interest aliens
among them reached our Southern border
annually The Daily Caller just reported
that 75,000 came in just the last nine
months DHS cannot possibly vet or even
interview a fraction of these numbers
raising the terrorism
risk and whereas about 20 aliens on the
terror watch list were caught at the
Southwest border in Prior years since
this Crisis began in 2021 through the
end of July border patrol apprehended an
almost implausibly large number of them
258 as of now those watch listed 258 are
just the ones border patrol managed to
catch border patrol failed to apprehend
a record breaking one .8 million
migrants who slipped into the
interior now those numbers don't seem
even possible between October 2022 and
August 2023 that's uh less than a year's
time more than 75,000 special interest
aliens were encountered encountered by
border patrol before the current border
crisis that number of special interest
aliens encountered by border patrol
officials was closer to
3,000 and these are just the the
migrants that were encountered the
actual number of special interest aliens
arriving at our borders is far larger
though it's impossible to know how many
and again these are just the people
coming from countries that the US
government believes are a highrisk uh
terrorist States we're also importing
the rest of the third world too without
any vetting whatsoever along with de
policing that's leading to a drastic
increase in violent crime rates in this
country all over the country we're not
taking in families or stable households
we're taking in mostly young men with no
ties to this country no loyalty to this
country and and very little to lose and
in response a lot more migrants are
coming our way this was the scene uh in
Mexico recently as yet another large
group of migrants apparently from Haiti
broke through barriers at a refugee
office look at
[Music]
this
so you see that
there uh and you can see the crowd for
yourself when Democrats talk about
illegal immigrants they want you to
imagine mothers with young children
fleeing poverty and oppression you know
the huddled masses yearning to breathe
free they tell us because they think
that a poem engraved on a large statue
carries the weight of Law and uh and and
should actually determine our
immigration policy but that that does
not really describe a great number of
the migrants pouring across the border
there are some mothers with young
children okay but what you just saw in
the video uh there was a bunch of young
military-aged
males and one of the things about those
people is that these are the sorts of
people who could be of use in their own
countries they could be trying to
improve their own homes fighting to make
their own countries prosperous or at
least
livable I mean imagine if these
countries actually retain
all of their young able-bodied strong
males to help uh actually literally and
in every other sense build the
country but instead they all come here
to take advantage of the welfare state
and they come here not always with the
best
intentions this is what happens when
politicians Promise free healthare to
Legal aliens as every Democratic party
presidential candidate did in the last
election it's what happens when the
president of the United States announces
his commitment to making America less
white and decid to defame any border
patrol officer who tries to enforce the
law it's what happens when we are more
concerned with other Count's borders
than our own this is why people from
Haiti and so many other countries are
heading for the US border which is not
even remotely secure Isis sees this
happening every terrorist organization
on the planet sees it happening they saw
the atrocities that Hamas was able to
commit against Israel which has has one
of the most closely surveilled and
guarded borders on the entire
planet there's no that they're looking
at that and then they're looking at our
open border and they're seeing an
opportunity to commit similar acts of
barbarism in this country it's not fear
mongering it's just the
reality courtesy of Isis there's reason
to believe that many of these terrist
are already
here and we can respond to that reality
either by uh uh closing and militarizing
the border and beginning mass
deportations or we can do nothing and
just get ready for the inevitable there
will be an attack the will pretend again
to relearn the lessons of 911 all over
again and American C citizens who are
the only citizens our leaders are
supposed to protect and defend will die
as a result thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcasts